lorsque tu as bien cherche une intro
d'accord
déjà j'ai l'impression que le casse tête
ils me regardent comme s'il était un
bonhomme
avant qu'on aille se casser la tête
laissez moi vous dire que cette vidéo
est en partenariat avec ea grêle si vous
connaissez ma chaîne depuis longtemps
vous connaissez grave j'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois si vous connaissez pas si
grave c'est une appli ainsi une
extension sécurisée et gratuite qui
permet de se faire rembourser une partie
de ses achats en ligne chez plus de 1700
vendeurs marchands partenaires alors il
ya tous les domaines tous les secteurs
la mode la technologie labotec sida ça
s'appelle le cash back excuse moi c'est
parce que j'étais derrière du coup tu
peux expliquer comment ça marche c'est
quoi le cashback lui qu'est ce que c'est
très simple bon sens n'est pas un gros
casse-tête je vous fait voir le cash
back en fait à chaque fois que tu fais
un achat en ligne sur un site ou à quai
avec igraal ça te génère des gains de
cash back dans ta cagnotte d'accord à
partir de 20 euros tu peux faire une
demande par en fait de paypal ou de
virement bancaire ou de chèques cadeaux
aussi directement pourquoi pas et tu
récupères comme ça ta cagnotte ça c'est
ça c'est mes 20 euros et ça c'est
cumulables par exemple avec les codes
promo que tu peux avoir sur les sites
marchands ou avec les soldes en cours
les soldes
ça c'est le mien ah si tu en veux tu
t'ouvres un conte comme ça chez igraal
directement ok mais comment c'est
possible parce que je suis l professeurs
et professeures elle promotionne dégrade
elles reviennent des halles et c'était
bizarre cet accent quand il fait un
achat en ligne de services touchent une
commission de la part du marchand qui
redistribue aux membres avec l'extension
gratuite et sécurisée qui installe dans
ton navigateur le site enfin l'extension
et indique directement les réductions
sur les sites que tu visites dont je
vais te revoir c'est plus simple alors
alors je lance l'appli igraal quand on
est sur l'appli graal là on a la queue
directement mais nous on va aller dans
la recherche on va aller chez cdiscount
et là on voit que ça s'active c'est à
dire que le cash back est en train de
s'activer et dès que ça va être versé
que ce bon cash back active et nous
pouvons donc continuer on peut naviguer
sur le site comme on le veut mais nous
on va les chercher une caméra frank s
comprend ça c'est pas mal ça les
batteries solaires et tous styles et
l'écologie l'adjectif cashback activée
on va aller voir le panier est donc là
le cash back il s'est additionné à la
promo en plus qui avait déjà choisir ma
livraison et je crois que c'est ici
qu'on va arrêter de filmer loïc quoi
exactement parce que sinon vous allez
voir l'adresse du bureau est donc là
maintenant les cages pack activé et donc
le cash back de cet achat va partir
directement dans ma cagnotte igraal si
vous voulez tester le service sachez
qu'avec le lien que je vous ai mis dans
la description vous avez 10 euros de
cadeaux offerts en guise de bienvenue au
lieu des 3 euros qu'ils offrent
habituellement c'est bon c'est bon pour
toi c'est clair
elle promotionne je suis elle promet on
commence par l'exploration
bon parce que ça s'enlève est en fait
tout s'ouvre pour le soir je ne sais pas
trop ce qui a à faire si apparemment
faut enlever la cellule verte d'énergie
qui lui permettraient de tuer tous toute
l'humanité pour que l'humanité le
moindre espoir de survivre à sa rage de
robot vous devez trouver et retirer sa
cellule d'énergie verte avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard je fais tourner la hutte
pour voir là on a on a ça qui est un
petit truc au bout attends je vais
l'exploration complète des sources il ya
un ajfer là il ya un deuil qui s'enlève
et à la place in orbit avec un petit
trou au bout là il ya un autre oeil
qu'on peut faire tourner mais
il se lève pointent le nez non je crois
qu'il bouge pas je crois le tout
l'impression que le nez collé la bouche
sa bougeotte
ici une oreille qui ne bouge pas là au
dos rien de spécial une oreille qui ne
bouge pas au dessus rien si ce n'est un
bruit de big
quand je faisais mon sens dyéla c'est
que j'essayais de comprendre l'espace
dans lequel elle évolue et a priori
c'est vraiment dans l'espace de la
bouche collée tu peux passer pauline qui
passe
tu vous connaissais pas pauline c'est
que vous connaissez pas la chaîne
secondaire le lien dans la description
est ici on a un petit trou par lequel on
ne voit rien je pense qu'on a fait le
tour je mette moulinette vous le dis je
suis fatigué j'ai la grippe et j'ai un
nom belgique vous pouvez me soutenir
mais le temps des laïcs lft
ait un vrai que la maj du pauvre alors
là j'ai ce mini bulls
chez ce petit bout puisqu'il est sorti
c'est pas un bouc c'est un oeil là je me
méfie parce que vous voyez il ya plein
de rainures et des fois une rainure peut
cacher quelque chose quelque chose qu'on
pourrait pousser ou tirer là vraiment a
priori il n'y a rien de spécial sauf
s'il a peut-être un aimant caché là
dedans
on va voir si un peu de métal là dedans
mais bien a priori pas du tout et
peut-être juste pas dément au bout en
bout
donc tâcher déjà bloqué quoi au début
j'étais allée vachement vite pas si vous
vous souvenez je les prie je fais ça
après là j'étais bloqué
[Musique]
est tout seul
comme je suis manager afin de parler si
vous voulez vous pouvez parler à ma
place dans les commentaires
je fais pas un massage de visage à
walter j'essaie de voir s'il ya un merde
[ __ ] j'y ai cru c'est de voir s'il y
avait un aimant dhr là dedans et je me
dis si un aimant quelque part là est un
aimant quelque part là je vais me sentir
sauf que là bas il ya comme une retenue
mais c'est juste parce que j'ai mis ça
dans la but est ici
ah bah oui j'ai un émoi inverser la
juste là
regardez merde ça ne fait plus
c'est pas fou j'avais un champ
magnétique qui est inversée et voilages
les hockey et je le prouve regardez je
peux faire bouger la boîte sans que ça
se touche peu oui donc c'est à quel
endroit c'est là là par contre regarder
avec les traces la la réunion je pense
qu'en fait ça c'est pas une réunion
naturel et que ça a été ouvert et
refermé alors qu'est-ce que je peux
faire avec ces thèmes on pouvait déjà on
peut chercher partout du couvoir c'était
locke pas simplement un peu j'ai cru
penser qu'il y avait un bruit
je suis pas beaucoup plus avancé
des maillots dessus
en dessous
se passer si je le mets à mi hauteur
là j'ai entendu un petit look
oui j'ai un jeu klauk là je peux si vous
entendez bien
donc là avec les mandla en passant sur
cette paroisse ça fait ch look en gros
ça tire quelque chose dans ce sens là
donc peut-être un truc que je pensais
que c'est un truc qui retenait l'oeil
comme ça et c'est ça ah oui d'accord ok
c'est qu'il n'a pas la forme circulaire
si apple est très stylée vous voyez où
pas
à 1100 m carrément ok d'accord enfin
c'est très simple donc là il ya un petit
bout de bois avec un aimant au bout fait
l'année un aimant il ya un aimant à
l'intérieur de la boîte ce qui fait que
quand c'est en place ça tient et ça le
repousse un peu dans ce sens là et si
cet aimant là tu viens le positionner la
conque il l'appelle et ça se rétracte et
c'est comme ça que tu peux sortir ce
truc dans ces styles et du coup nous
voilà avec deux arbitres vide ça et ça
on a commencé à démonter wolter alors
lui est-ce qu'il a un iman quelque part
si j'ai un verset 2
ça ne lui fait rien
c'est chiant parce que si je mets mes
recettes là loïc va gueuler mais moi je
vois pas très bien ce qui a 9 ans
[Musique]
j'ai lu 8 du fond là l'anneau du fond
ils bougent un peu quand j'appuie pas
beaucoup mais là c'est pas du chi l'ha
c'est un petit peu c'est un tout petit
peu de relief contre la pulpe de mon
doigt ça vient on appelle ça la pulpe
vont pas l'après c'est
comme ça bouge grave
ok alors [ __ ] donc comment je vous
faire voir ça
ce truc là le dernier à nous en bas suis
que je trouvais qu'ils bougeaient là eh
ben il celui du fond je peux pousser
vers l'intérieur et du cou et l'autre et
l'autre avance du goût dans sa cellule
et si je suis comme ça là vous voyez ou
pas que ça avance aux attendes il ya un
clic en relief et si je lâche
mes repas tac là je pense que peut-être
vous voyez là ce que j'ai réussi à faire
en fait ça tous et à nos jeux l'a
enfoncé par là et sa sortie par ici ok
qu'est ce que j'en fait ça pour
l'instant sais pas si je relâche j'ai
tout qui retombe
c'est chiant parce que si je m'étais
l'halloween avec le livre
parce que je peux le plus bloquée comme
ça non plus j'ai ça c'est monté par
ouais j'ai ce petit truc la petite barre
en métal qui vient de tomber je crois
que quand j'étais comme ça quand j'étais
comme ça qui est peut-être tombé du
fonds reprenons on a un beau buzz un
oeil un aimant et une petite barre qui
est en fer puisque clairement aimant
table et rappelez vous on a un petit
trou sur la tête de walter donc on se le
tente
on la voit là ça a fait bouger
directement la bouche
ça fait bouger la bouche
c'est qu'on peut le relever comme ça
c'est sûr que c'est important ça l'a
trop fait bouger c'est bizarre parce que
quand je bouge la bouche ça me repousse
le le petit truc vers l'extérieur du
trou ou alors faut pas le pousser
complètement
je pensais que ça allait lever et faire
claque ça ne l'a fait bouger voilà ça
fait bouger un peu
[ __ ] je la vois clairement passé là
dans la rainure qui est ici je vois mon
bout de métal qui passe je ne fais comme
ça
il fallait relâcher un petit peu et du
cou aulas
ok alors attends
un [ __ ] les rainures mais on vote pour
changer cette table est arrêté avec le
tabla règnera ça je pense que c'était là
dedans à [ __ ] c'est s'accuser le bruit
et c'est ça le mouvement que faisait
donc qui devait être un intérieur de la
bouche donc la bouche a été retenu par
sa sa salle et dans la petite encoche
qui a ici
il fallait effectivement l'enfance elfe
font entre guillemets et le laisser
ressortir et pour que ça tombe plus
facilement de retourner l'ensemble bille
rouge pour que l'humanité le moindre
espoir de survivre à sa rage de robot
vous devez trouver et retirer sa cellule
d'énergie verte avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard on est sur du rouge clairement
du coup là à l'intérieur on a un titre
européen se bouge là je sais pas si vous
voyez à l'intérieur de la bouche on a un
petit bout de bois comme ça aussi
j'appuie on peut le pousser telles
distractions
non hélas
techniquement il a rien qui branche
tu es venu contrôler qu'est ce qui se
passait là je te propose de me soumettre
une hypothèse avant de partir ça je
crois vraiment que je l'exploité ça
aussi ce petit bout là ce petit but mais
aussi en gros je me suis jamais servi de
ça alors vraiment comme je sais mais
je me suis jamais servi de ça je me suis
jamais servi de
huawei est là là là en fait c'était ça
où ça s'était rangé à la base au caire
si non vraiment j'ai donne moi une
action à tester avant de partir et ben
ouais ouais bah c'est bien tout ça il ya
moi qui bouge sion alors là c'est très
très kia ca qui bouge tu as puis là je
serai aussi je redis mon truc est
d'accord ouais eh ben je te propose de
continuer à chercher d'accord et
peut-être qu'avec ces petites boules
si c'est de les mettre dans des dans les
trous ça va déclencher un truc allez je
voudrais que j'appelle la vidéo mais la
petite boule dans des trous peut-être ça
va déclencher un truc c'est un peu long
comme titre on va suivre les
recommandations de loïc jeu cette petite
boule dans le petit trou du fond
ça ne déclenche rien l'ama temps il ya
d'autres trous il ya d'autres
trouvailles et le petit trou là va
jamais ressortir le truc
là le petit plus la photo je la vois
plus
le trou noir et profond
du titre dans les commentaires mais
quand je mets ma boule à l'entrée du
trou ça rentre à peine et après quand je
l'enfoncent je vois bien que la boule je
la vois plus comme s'il y avait un trou
après le trou d'air de trous dans un
trou
dans un faux mon nez d'un point haut
j'essaie de voir si un chemin ou pas du
tout
[Musique]
ça fait ch
ok là elle est en train de rouler ici là
souligne
la la la donc si je fais ça je vais lui
laisser plus d'espacé
[Musique]
on l'entend elle roule plus
la selle le bloc moi j'ai ce truc là qui
bouge bien là qui ne bougent plus parce
que la bille doit être derrière et je
suis en train de me demander s'il faut
pas que je pousse avec ça sur la bi pour
qu'elle pousse dessus c'est peut-être
pas bien en face et ma théorie elle vaut
le coup
fatal et de suisse oui
mais regardons la gare aux
lacets la fin
mais j'ai trouvé la petite boule
d'énergie verte c'est ça qu'il fallait
trouver ou alors la bille a changé de
couleur
mais attends l'a16 et vaudoises [ __ ]
c'est vrai style et
j'ai adoré sow sillery nahd 2 à 2 je
mettrais au moins de jeu désolé les
québécois je sais que c'est
insupportable pour vous quand quelqu'un
imite l'accent québécois pour me faire
pardonner sachez que je viens jouer chez
vous fin août c'est pas une blague
restez connectés restez connecté le
québec et montréal aussi
parce que tu es mon réel en vrai les
biens est allé en vrai elle est bien au
plat attention à castets mais bien
résolus que s'il est bien résolue ce
qu'apparemment il y en a un que j'ai par
fait l'autre fois c'était la clé que
j'ai refait en off en vrai
pas tellement d'intérêt parce qu'il n'y
avait rien à voir mais je crois que la
moitié des commentaires disent à cause
de toi l'oit il te plait garde cette
partie au montage je vais remettre alors
pour le remettre ça va être ça comme ça
le casse tête est résolu je te laisse le
refaire pour la chaîne secondaire ou
alors ouais l'arquois des vidéos n'ont
pas encore c'est moins la fin j'ai trop
de fièvre j'en peux plus ok alors merci
beaucoup à israël d'avoir été en
partenariat avec cette vidéo le lien est
disponible dans la description si vous
passez par lui il ya 10 euros offerts à
l'inscription au lieu de 3 euros merci
graal merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette
casse tête j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas que je suis en tournée
dans toute la france mais il ya plus
beaucoup de place donc n'hésitez pas à
réserver toutes les infos sont bien
entendu il n'y a plus de galade il ya
plus de règle à ce disque est vraiment
plus de place mais juin mais sachez
qu'ils aient je suis quand même en
tournée ça fait plaisir pour ceux qui
seront là vous tient au courant pour le
reste de la tournée là je vous mets une
vidéo casse-tête 1 est il là je vous
mets une autre vidéo qui peut vous
intéresser et ça je n'en doute pas à
très bientôt prenez soin de vous ciao